[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con hoy nos
acompaña el doctor carlos eduardo pérez
médico infectólogo de la universidad
nacional de colombia y asesor científico
de france 24 doctor un gusto saludarlo
nuevamente hoy hablaremos de brasil que
enfrenta una nueva política frente a la
pandemia de coronavirus con un discurso
más ligado a la preocupación por lo que
hay o ocurre luego de conocerse que se
superaron los 300 mil muertos y después
de superar la marca de 3.000 muertes
diarias porque esta segunda ola de ccoo
y 19 en brasil- doctor es mucho más
virulenta y letal que la primera es
parte de causada por las nuevas
variantes
sin duda se unen muchos factores en
brasil la situación al de brasil es
caótica hasta el borde del colapso su
sistema de salud en algunas ciudades y
las informaciones que nos llegan de
colegas y el medio de comunicación
muestran digamos que es respuesta a las
variantes a la no armonía que hay entre
el estado y la ciencia entre el gobierno
local el gobierno regional y el gobierno
central y todo este desorden ha
terminado en que los esfuerzos para
controlar la pandemia sean muy limitados
y hoy ese compromiso político esa falta
de compromiso político en no hacer caso
a la ciencia de las medidas que son muy
tibias la tasa de vacunación muy baja
pues ha traído este problema tan grande
que hay en brasil ahora a partir de este
jueves 25 de marzo empieza a un mayor
ritmo de vacunación una medida que hace
parte de la nueva política del
presidente visionario luego de dar un
aparente marcha atrás en su
controvertida gestión tener un ritmo más
acelerado garantizará la disminuir
de estos contagios doctor
en este momento toda ayuda pero la
backus los efectos de la vacunación no
son inmediatos los efectos de la
vacunación son en la segunda semana de
la segunda dosis más o menos al mes mes
y medio de que las personas sin munición
es decir que te independientemente de la
tasa de vacunación es importante la
exacerbación de casos porque la
vacunación es un proyecto a mediano
plazo para contar la pandemia pero no
hay inmediato acortar la pandemia sin
duda hay que acelerar la la vacunación
pero no va a ser la solución final en
este momento se necesita deshacer los
casos
hacer las medidas de confinamiento
armonizar estado ciencia y regiones para
que puedan salir adelante
ahora a un año de la pandemia bolsonaro
sigue respaldando el uso de medicamentos
como la hidroxi cloroquina y la
ivermectina muchos lo siguen además qué
efectos está trayendo a esto
y ese ha sido un absoluto desastre
porque no tiene ninguna evidencia
científica y lo sigue recomendando ayer
en su pronunciamiento dijo que iba a
armar un nuevo equipo para coordinar en
la respuesta pero que recomendaba el
tratamiento con estos medicamentos no
tienen sustento científico y dan una
falsa seguridad o un falso tratamiento
hacia la comunidad que cree en sus
gobernantes y no evitan la enfermedad
todo lo contrario puede empeorar porque
dilata que las personas lleguen a los
servicios médicos y pueden probar esto
es una medida desafortunada y una
desarmonía entre la ciencia y la
política que no hemos visto en ninguna
región del mundo ahora doctor si no se
controla la pandemia en brasil qué
repercusiones traerá esto a nivel global
sin duda dan las grandísimas porque los
linajes virales como el de manaos y
probablemente otros linajes que se estén
construyendo con esa alta replicación de
virus va a producir que este virus mute
y que probablemente incluso las vacunas
no puedan ser efectivas o que estos
linajes ganen virulencia y puedan salir
a otros países los virus no reconocen
fronteras es decir que se pueden estar y
afectar globalmente y por eso la
demencia de hecho la advertencia de que
la situación en brasil es un control de
prioridad no de la región sino del mundo
tenemos que estar todos ayudando para
que esto no suceda doctor ante esto es
necesario cerrar entonces las fronteras
de la región con brasil y además por
cuánto tiempo
sí sin duda en este momento estas
medidas un poco draconianas de cerrar
fronteras de evitar la migración de las
personas van a ser necesarias una vez se
controle pues se reactivará es el tiempo
solamente hará el proceso de vacunación
la disminución del número de casos y
sobre todo la biología molecular esa
vigilancia que hay que hacer sobre la
aparición de nuevos linajes para que no
sean exportados a otras regiones del
mundo
recordemos que la la variación de
emanado la variante manual fue detectado
fue en concón no fue detectada en brasil
en los primeros casos es decir que se
emita vigilancia molecular y una alta
concentración y que no haya dispersión
de estos linajes en el país ni a otros
países doctor gracias por su tiempo por
estar aquí con nosotros en france 24 que
tengo ustedes un muy buen día ustedes
también gracias por acompañarnos en
estas cinco minutos con
[Música]